I sold my condo sold all my stuff packed
my car and I drove straight to
California from Baltimore it's like okay
I don't know anything about the gym
business so I'll just email a bunch of
gym owners and see if they'll just like
let me work for free I gave me like 40
gyms one guy got back to me and he was
like yeah come on out you can work for
free so I was like all right awesome
shut up at this guy's doorstep and he
was like this is really creepy I was not
really actually expecting you to do this
I was like what do you want me to do and
he's like I don't know like I have stuff
to do you can hang out here for a little
bit and he's like where are you staying
and I was like I don't know I just got
here I just drove to your gym from my
house in Baltimore you have nowhere to
stay and I was like no I figured I
figured out where was this located in
California so you drove from Baltimore
to California yeah he was he was
surprised you even did it yeah you
didn't call him while you're driving
like on the way like hey man just
letting you know I'm like I'm on the way
I mean we talked once and I was like all
right I'll be there I didn't even have
his phone number he just showed up at
his house I showed up at his gym